good morning everyone
i want to begin by uh thanking the
secretary of defense
and our freeman director
uh for joining me today
uh
we were joking earlier now we're really
joking
when you need something done call on the
military
and again fema will make sure it gets
done
uh look um
we're about to get a covet 19 briefing
from military medical teams on the
ground in arizona
michigan and new york
they're part of a major deployment of
our nation's armed forces to help
hospitals across the country manage this
surge of the omicron virus
surges have an impact on hospitals
like all health care workers they are
heroes and i'm grateful
for what they do
but before we begin i want to provide an
update on our fight against coven 19 and
announce new steps
first the update
i know we're all frustrated as we enter
this new year omicron variant is causing
millions of cases and record
hospitalizations
i've been i've been saying that as we
remain in this pandemic this is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated
and i mean by this right now both
vaccinated and unvaccinated people are
testing positive
but what happens after that could not be
more different
if vaccinated people test positive
they're overwhelmingly have either no
symptoms at all or they have mild
symptoms
and if they're if you're unvaccinated if
they test positive
there are you are 17 times more likely
to get hospitalized
as a result
they're crowding their hospitals leaving
little room for anyone else who might
have a heart attack or an injury in an
automobile accident or any injury at all
and yes the unvaccinated are dying from
covet 19.
but here's the deal
because we fully vaccinated nearly 210
million americans the majority of the
country is safe from severe covet 19
consequences
that's why even as the number of cases
among the vaccinated americans go up
deaths are down dramatically from last
winter
for example
before this vaccination requirement the
united states assuming united airlines
was uh was averaging one employee dying
a week from cover 19.
after implementing its requirement
it's led to 99 of its employees being
vaccinated
united had 3 600 employees test positive
but zero hospitalizations
zero debts in over eight weeks
but as long as we have tens of millions
of people who will not get vaccinated
we're going to have full hospitals and
needless deaths so the single most
important thing
to determine your outcome in this
pandemic is getting vaccinated
if you're not vaccinated join the nearly
210 million american people who are
vaccinated
if you are vaccinated join the nearly 80
million americans who have gotten the
booster shot
with the strongest protection possible
vaccines are safe
they're free and they're widely
available so do it today please for your
sake to say to your kids and say to the
country
now i don't like to uh
you know
outline the next steps we're taking
against uh i'd like to outline the next
steps are taken against over on the the
omnicron variant
vaccinations are obviously the most
important thing we're doing
but they're but they are not the only
important thing
first
masking masking masking is an important
tool to control the spread of covet 19.
and when you're indoors in public places
you should wear the mask
and you're
there there are a lot you know
lots of different kinds of masks out
there
and the center for the center for
disease control and prevention the cdc
says that wearing a well-fitting mask
of of any of them is certainly better
than not wearing a mask if it's well
fitting what foot over your nose
and but it's about one-third about
one-third of america's report they don't
wear a mask at all
as i've said in the last two years
please wear a mask
if you're in a you know i think it's
part of your patriotic duty it's not
that comfortable
it's a pain in the neck
but
i've taken every action i can as
president to require people to wear
masks in federal buildings and on
airplanes and trains because their
internet they cross state lines
i make sure that our doctors and nurses
and first responders have the mask they
need
never again we're going to have our
nurses using homemade masks and garbage
bags over their clothing for hospital
because they don't have the gowns
we've more than tripled our stockpile of
the most protective specialized n95 mask
since coming into office
this is going to make sure that there
will be an ample supply of healthcare
workers and first responders
we also have helped make sure that high
quality masks are widely available in
ample supply at affordable prices sold
online and in stores
but i know that for some americans the
mask is not always affordable or
convenient to get so
next week we'll announce
we'll announce how
we are making high quality masks
available to american people the
american people for free
i you know i know we all wish that we
could finally be done with wearing masks
i get it
but there is a really important tool
to stop the spread especially of a
highly transmittable homocrine variant
so please please wear the mask
second
testing
we're seeing real improvement in testing
when i got here
we were doing fewer than two million
tests a day
now
and it's changed none of these tests
were at home or rapid tests
this month it's estimated
that we will hit approximately 15
million tests a day
and we'll have over 307
million at home rapid test in january
alone
that's a huge leap
we've taken a number of steps including
invoking the defense production act
as early as last february to ramp up
production
you know and we're on track we're on
track to roll out a website next week
where you can order free tests shipped
to your home
and in addition to the 500 million half
a billion tests that are in the process
of being acquired to ship to you homes
for free today i'm directing my team to
procure an additional half a bill
additional 500 million more tests to
distribute for free
i mean a billion tests in total
to meet future demand
and we'll continue to work with the
retailers and online and on online
retailers
to increase availability
and for those who want an immediate test
we continue to add fema testing sites
so that there are more than
more free in-person testing sites
for those of you with insurance
you can get reimbursed for eight tests a
month
for those without insurance we have over
20 000
free testing sites all around the
country
you can find the nearest testing sites
for you
by googling covid
test near me google covid
test
near me
and to help uh lead our federal testing
program
i've talked i i've i've extremely i've
tapped uh dr tom
i hope i pronounced it anything angel
ingalls me
correct is that right jeff
uh and uh he's one of the world's
leading infectious disease experts and
i'm grateful for his willingness to help
tackle this challenge
third thing
today we'll discuss our hospital
response efforts
just thanks to this
just since thanksgiving
over 800 military and other federal
emergency personnel have been deployed
to 24 states tribes and territories
including over 350 military doctors
nurses and medics helping staff the
hospitals are in short supply this is on
top of more than 14 000 national guard
members that are active activated in 49
states
these deployments in my direction and
thanks to the american rescue plan are
fully paid for by the federal government
we've shipped over 5.5 million pieces of
protect personal protective equipment
gloves gowns masks
to protect front-line healthcare workers
we're shipping more treatments of
covet-19 which includes antiviral pills
then at any point during this pandemic
in addition i've directed fema to work
with every state territory in the
district of columbia to make sure they
have enough hospital bed capacity
today i'm announcing our next deployment
of six additional federal medical teams
a total of more than 120 military
medical personnel
to six hard-hit states
michigan new york
new jersey
ohio rhode island
and let me close with this
it's been a long road
but what's clear
as we get through this when everybody
does their part
no matter where you live
no matter your political party we've got
to fight this together
unfortunately while our military's
stepping up as they always do
there are others sitting on the
sidelines and we're standing in the way
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop
covet 19 is one of the most formidable
enemies america has ever faced
we've got to work together not against
each other we're america
we can do this
so the military medical teams on the
ground thank you for all in everything
you're doing
and i'll stop here so we can get to the
briefing started
thank you for taking the time
officials say most americans will get
coveted at
folks we'll talk about that later come
on
[Music]
thank you so much
me too
we'll start in one minute
all right
uh mr president we'll start with
administrator chris well whose team at
fema as you know has been on the front
lines of the covid response over to you
administrator and everything else
a lot going on these days mr president
thank you jeff
uh mr president as you know fema has
been working in the kobe mission since
day one
our objective has always remained the
same to protect and save as many lives
as possible
during every disaster fema's strength is
our ability to coordinate with other
stakeholders with our federal partners
with our state partners with private and
non-profit partners